-Hi, Spivey.
-Hi! Oh, my God.
This is so exciting.
-This is so exciting.
It is such a trip to have yo
back in the building.
We met in this building.
-We did.
-We started the same year, 2001,
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Yes, right. Right after 9/11.
-We're in the same class.
Right after 9/11.
-We're in the same class, yeah
-And I feel like people
who come together at "SNL"
are always sort of
intensely close.
But I think the fact that we
started days before 9/11,
made us even closer.
It was a tricky time
to work in comedy.
And I was saying about
this earlier.
You're one of my favorite people
to be around
in terms of when
you have to write
because you are a brillian
writer who is very honest
about how hard it is
and how much you hate it.
-Oh, it's horrible.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a horrible nightmare
-Yeah.
-It's like a hard turd.
[ Laughter ]
Every time you sit down
to write something,
it's like living a nightmare
over and over.
[ Laughter ]
And, by the way,
I'm so grateful to be doing it
I don't mean to sound like -
-Yeah.
-'Cause I think we were saying
there's some writers who,
they're very confident.
They walk down the halls.
You're like,
"What do you got tonight?"
And they're like, "I got
a couple of really good ideas.
Whereas every time I asked you
you'd be like,
"Y'all, I got nothin'."
-I got nothin'!
[ Laughter ]
That's horrible.
-I do want to prove how much -
how little that was true.
These are some of the franchises
you wrote.
There she is.
-Poehler as Kaitlin.
-Kaitlin.
Personal favorite of mine.
There's "Bronx Beat."
-Oh, "Bronx Beat."
-Yeah.
-The world is gonna blow up.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Donatella."
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
Look at Horatio.
-Horatio as Elton John.
-Elton John.
-I can't believe he didn't
get to play Elton John
in that movie they made.
-Why didn't he?
-Come on.
-I thought the same thing.
-And then of course you --
-Oh, my God,
"Oprah's favorite things."
The studio blew up.
-The studio blew up.
-And then you wrote
a less popular, I think,
in the annals of "SNL."
-It delighted like four people
-For Billy Bob Thornton,
which I think was
our fourth or fifth show,
and it was called
"Fenced-in area."
-"Fenced-in area."
-And there I am.
On the same night that I gav
Blake Shelton [bleep]
for having a mullet.
[ Laughter ]
There I am.
[ Applause ]
-I want you to have this hai
in real life.
-I'm so attracted to you
in this.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-With this look.
-This is a very specific
kind of sketch that you wrote.
You're from North Carolina
-Yeah.
-You are enamored by this world.
You wrote on "King of the Hill."
-Yes.
-Explain real quick the premis
behind "Fenced-in area"
because it is
as small an idea --
-It's a whiff of a concept
[ Laughter ]
It barely clung to
the paper as I was writing
Billy Bob fenced in an are
in his backyard
that was about as big as thi
little stage-a-roo thing.
And then he had big dreams about
what he was gonna do with it
Like, meaning, "I might pu
a pool in there."
[ Laughter ]
I might buy some rottweilers
put them in there.
And then so it was
ruining his life.
So then Seth was his littl
brother who showed up to say
"Please come inside
and stop drinking beer
and staring at
your fenced-in area."
[ Laughter ]
And he had
this beautiful mullet
and he was saying, "Let's go key
Jeff Turner's four-wheeler."
[ Laughter ]
-And this is a true story.
When Billy Bob Thornton was on
this show a couple years ago
I had not seen him --
16 years I had not seen him.
And I walked into
his dressing room.
And he went, "Fenced-in area."
[ Laughter ]
So it landed with him.
-Yes. Well, I love him.
Oh, my God.
-"Bless the Harts"
is similar to this world.
Yes?
-Yes.
-And is this inspired by
where you came from
and the people you knew?
-Oh, God, yeah. Yeah.
It's all about my hometown
Everything I write secretl
takes place in the South,
which you know that.
Even if it's not the South
in my mind it's the South
and it also might be
in the '80s, the 1980s.
[ Laughter ]
But yeah.
In the vein of
my Southern obsession,
"Bless the Harts" is
this Billy Bob character.
It's my hometown
and it's people I grew up with
And it's sort of like
a "King of the Hill"
that takes place
in North Carolina
with female leads, let's say
-Yeah, 'cause you have --
Some of the voices of people
heard in the clip --
Kristen Wiig, Maya Rudolph
the incredibly talented
Jillian Bell.
-Mm-hmm.
-Ike Barinholtz.
-Yep.
-And it must be so fun to know
that you have these people
whose voices over the years,
you've come to learn so well
-Oh, my gosh. Yeah.
It's a delight writing for the
'cause it's just like family
It's like our twin language.
Anyone from the Groundling
or "SNL" or whatever,
you do speak
the same comedic language.
It is like -- it feels -- it's
like orgasmic writing for that
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's just been -- I'
the luckiest girl in the world